you know it's funny when you're speaking
it took me to iran
and i lived in iran 10 years and one of
the reasons why the shah
you know they eventually kicked them out
the second time there was
a group to shop fear the most and it was
a group called today
and two days were communists who had
escaped
lenin or stalin you know this could have
been armenians this could have been
you know russians who came to iran
because the shop was trying to make it
more westernized and he had the battle
against the hezbollahs and
you know the extremists and today
he feared two days so much that every
two day just think about two day equals
communist same thing these are people
that swore by the book karl marx
communist manifesto my family mother's
side
they the communist manifesto bible was
first then it was the bible it was like
to them
that was their bible i grew up with that
and he kept
every time he found him he kept
arresting them he found ways to
eliminate them because he knew long term
these guys were trying to create a
revolution in iran
to divide the entire nation that was
growing at a pace that was about to pass
uk
specifically with all the new contracts
of oil he was going to renew in 1979
obviously in in the contract that was
signed in 1954
for 25-year contract with france germany
russia and i believe
ir us and then that was his fear
so where i'm going with this is
you know the whole idea where general uh
mark milly
who you you know general mark milley he
came out and he
uh uh opposed folks like yourself and
here's a man who says look what's wrong
with mike
i've read communist manifesto and i've
read you know i don't know what the
other book he talked about walter i
don't know what the other book would
have been it would have been ein rand or
atlas schragler
but he said another book he says i've
read both books he says i want to learn
both books what's wrong with learning
both books what's wrong with doing this
do you think there's a problem with even
allowing an idea that dangerous enter
the minds of people or are you from the
school of thought of
if we're going to develop a strong
immune system as individuals
sometimes hurt immunity means you have
to face opposing ideas for you to get
stronger what are your thoughts on that
that's an excellent
question that you've asked i think that
it's important
for us to learn history first off i'll
say that up front
the good the bad and the ugly it's
important
not to shy away from our ugly past as a
country either
um it's one thing to study and learn
about
marxism for example to study the
communist manifesto to study lenin's
writings
to study mao's writings uh what stalin
was doing
uh during his time in the soviet union
it's one thing
to study ideology and these things it's
an
it's an entirely different thing
altogether to
infuse our institutions with its tenets
and its
vocabulary okay entirely different it's
important and healthy to have dialogue
it's
unhealthy to impose viewpoints
political viewpoints and ideology on
people and insist that to disagree
is to identify yourself as either racist
or bigoted
or and you start throwing labels around
it people if they disagree
with your views if they disagree with
your understanding of history
that's where things begin you mentioned
fear
in iran there was a fear there is a
climate of fear
that we've generated for ourselves very
rapidly in this country
where we politicize the environment
and you know you see people losing their
jobs if they disagree with a particular
political stance or political ideology
well i'll tell you what that translates
into
in an organization like our armed forces
and this is a very important point
our service members in my view
showed her an unfair burden of remaining
apolitical
when political ideology comes face to
face with them
and they've been trained their entire
lives to know that they're supposed to
remain apolitical because to disagree
is to necessarily be viewed as
politically partisan
but to sit silent because of a climate
of fear
is to allow for you your values
your belief systems your own viewpoint
to be steamrolled
by a different incompatible political
ideology so if you like this sort of
short club from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
you